all right get this a texas border county
declaring an emergency over the surge of
migrants testing positive for covet
it's the largest city mcallen building
temporary tents now to house them they
just started popping up right in the
middle of the city
this comes as we learn more than 7 000
coveted positive migrants have been
released into the city
since february fifteen hundred of them
in the last week alone
what about title forty-two here to react
former acting dhs secretary heritage
foundation visiting fellow chad wolfe
chat i thought was turning everybody
around except unaccompanied minors
and families what's going on here
yeah well again this is the result of a
crisis
that's been going on for now six months
at the border and it will continue until
the bite administration
actually implements policies that adhere
to that rule of law along that border
what we're seeing is communities across
the border declaring these emergencies
and it's no surprise
when you have over 210 000 illegal
apprehensions in one month alone
that is astronomical and what we see is
what they're doing is that catch and
release so they're releasing they're
having mass releases in these
communities
letting these individuals go and then
it's on these communities
to provide the transportation the public
safety and all the social services
for these individuals so of course they
need these states of emergency they need
additional funding from states
this is why the governor of texas
governor abbott is taking such
measures because the federal government
is not enforcing the rule of law in that
border today so you got seven thousand
migrants fifteen hundred test positive
covet nineteen
some are getting free vaccines which by
the way is a magnet oh my goodness i
can't get a vaccine to my country why
don't i come to america i'll get housing
health care and a free vaccine but some
are turning them down
let me ask some as when you were at this
uh the federal level
was there anything locally that could
pressure you to act
is there anything that really put the
heat on you to do something
because a lot of cities to feel totally
frustrated
well absolutely we listen to our local
law enforcement
and local political leaders along that
border they are living in that community
they know those communities first hand
and so our job at the federal level was
to support them so we would listen to
them
we would try to understand what was
going on and then we would i would
specifically
devote resources at the federal level to
enforce
and to back up what they needed and we
don't see that today
instead you see law enforcement you see
mayors begging for help from the federal
government
and the federal government doing little
to respond to their pleas
yeah here's uh the dhs on whether
they'll vaccine
mo will give a vaccine to migrants
because they're considering doing
but talk about not seeing around the
corner and how this would be a magnet
here's the quote
we continue to monitor and reassess
covert 19 protocols at this time our
protocols
have not changed which means via test
positive they give you a hotel to stay
in
and uh and and uh and quarantine do you
really think they're doing that
yeah well i i think it's important to
keep in mind that this talk right now
about how they could
vaccinate illegal immigrants coming
across that border
is simply because they've gotten caught
they've gotten caught over the last
several months
in trying to answer questions of why are
you letting individuals go
right that are not vaccinated and
perhaps coveted positive
and they can't answer that question so
now they're scrambling but what we do
know
is that a lot of these migrants will not
take the vaccine
and will continue to be released into
communities every day
and that's simply the wrong approach but
we are addressing the symptoms of the
issue
what the bite administration should be
doing and they're not doing is actually
stopping these individuals from coming
to the border in the first place which
is
again getting that rule of law back on
the border providing consequences to
illegal behavior they're not addressing
that issue and they continue to address
the symptoms
right and you're going to continue to
see these numbers in the crisis as long
as they do that
and chad look we're the mexican marines
at their southern border
why is mexico city letting everyone fly
in and then walk through
so you could put pressure or work with
mexico as a partner
but we've ignored that the vice
president makes two zoom calls and it
goes on vacation
yeah yeah absolutely right you've got to
put more pressure
governor of mexico can do more uh but
i don't know that the biden
administration is willing to push them
as the as president trump did over the
last four years
and you need your partners not only in
mexico but in central america
doing more and you need to work with
them but as we've seen both the
president of mexico as well as others
really viewed that this administration
is encouraging this illegal behavior
is occurring that thousands and
thousands of folks coming through their
border as well
it's frustrating uh because it's all
fixable and then there's lives are at
stake
uh chad wolfe thanks so much yeah hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on fox you
can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now